hey this is press tow
Walker this video covers two problems
that involve absolute
values problem one solve for all real
values of X such that the absolute value
of x - one minus the absolute value of x
+ 1 plus X is less than zero this is
adapted from a tweet by gyth
chaho problem two if x is a real number
what is the product of all the roots of
the equation the square root of 5 * the
absolute value of x + 8 is equal to the
square OT of x^2 - 16 this is adapted
from a 2011 AMC problem the AMC 10B is
one of the Olympiad qualifying tests in
America pause the video if you'd like to
give these problems a try and when
you're ready keep watching to learn how
to solve the these
[Music]
problems let's solve problem
one to solve this problem we will recall
the definition of the absolute value of
x the absolute value of x is equal to x
if x is greater than or equal to zero
and it's equal to the opposite of x if x
is less than
zero so if x is greater than or equal to
Z the graph of Y is equal to absolute
value of x will be Y is equal to X when
X is less than Z it'll be equal to the
opposite of X so it'll look like this so
we have a v-shaped
graph so to solve this problem we need
to look at what's inside of the absolute
value
signs so here we need to know when x -1
is greater than or equal to zero this is
when X is greater than or equal to 1 we
also need to know when x + 1 is greater
than or equal to Z and that is when X is
greater than or equal
to1 so now we need to look at both of
these together so imagine we have a
number line clearly 1 and Nega 1 are
critical
values for X - 1 it will be positive
when X is greater than or equal to 1 and
otherwise it's going to be
negative for x + 1 it's going to be
positive all the way until X is equal to
1 and then it's going to be negative so
we have three different cases to
consider one case both of these are
positive in another case one is positive
the other is negative and in the other
case they're both negative so let's work
through these three different
cases so we'll start out by supposing X
is greater than or equal to
1 so both of them are going to be
positive in this case so we have x -1
minus the quantity x + 1 + x is less
than
Z we can simplify this and we end up
with the result that X is less than 2 so
we need to combine that with X is
greater than or equal to 1 so we get 1
is less than or equal to X is less than
2 the next case is when -1 is less than
or equal to X is less than
1 in that case this one is going to be
negative and the other one is going to
be positive so we have the opposite of x
-1 minus the quantity x + 1 + x is less
than 0 so you just need to be careful
about the signs and grouping the terms
when you work it all out you end up with
0 is less than x now we need to combine
it with the condition that -1 is less
than or equal to X is less than 1 so
this works out to 0 is less than x is
less than one finally if x is less than
NE 1 then both of the terms inside of
these absolute values will be less than
zero so we will have the opposite of x
-1 minus the opposite of x + 1 + x is
less than zero now just carefully work
through all of these sign changes and
group- likee terms and you end up with
the result that X is less than -2 we
combine this with X is less than 1 and
we just end up with X is less than
-2 so these are the conditions we
have we have X is less than -2 or 0 is
less than x is less than 1 or 1 is less
than or equal to X is less than 2 we can
visualize the solution graphically this
is the graph of the function the
absolute value of x -1 minus the
absolute value of x + 1 + x we need to
see where this graph is less than zero
so here is one interval X is less than
-2 here is another interval 0 is less
than x is less than 1 and then we have 1
is less than or equal to X is less than
2 in fact we can combine these two
conditions together so we just have 0 is
less than x is less than
two and that's the solution X is less
than -2 or 0 is less than x is less than
two now let's solve problem
two we have a square root on both sides
of the equation so we will Square both
sides of the equation since we squared
both sides we just want to make sure we
don't create any extraneous Roots so
we'll be careful to check the answer at
the end so the equation we have is 5 *
the absolute value of x + 8 is equal to
x^2 - 16 we could go to the definition
of the absolute value of x and approach
it by cases but in this problem there's
another neat way you can solve
it x^2 is exactly the same thing as the
square of the absolute value of x so we
can substitute that into this
equation we will now subtract five times
the absolute value of X and subtract
eight from both sides of the equation so
we have 0 is equal to the square of the
absolute value of x minus 5 * the
absolute value of x
-4 so if we look at this equation we
actually have a quadratic equation in
the term the absolute value of x in this
case we can actually Factor this
equation 24 has factors of 8 and three
which differ by five so we get one
factor is the absolute value of x minus
8 and the other factor is the absolute
value of x + 3 so this gives two
possibilities either the absolute value
of x is equal 8 or the absolute value of
x is equal to -3 but we know the
absolute value of x has to be greater
than or equal to zero so it can't
possibly be equal to -3 so we exclude
this case so the only possibility is
that the absolute value of x is equal to
8 we now just checked that both
Solutions X is equal to8 or X is equal
to 8 will work in the original equation
and in fact they do both work so X is
equal to 8 and X is equal to 8 are Roots
which means the product of all the roots
is8 * 8 which equal
-64 and that's the
answer thanks for making us one of the
best communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a
time